今回はまたとんでもないもの見つけましたよ！！
こちらっ！
fire Wallet
見てください
財布から火が出ています
説明文は全部英語海外の商品でございます
この商品は１８歳以上の人しか売ってないらしいですね
日本語表記もありますこちらに
財布を開くと炎が出るとっ！
まぁ色々やり方があるんですけども
まぁ案の定マサキが今から家に来るんですけれど
hahahahahaha
財布を新しくしたという設定で
どうまさきへへへって
こう見せてー
炎が燃えるっていうドッキリをしようと思います
なんかねDVDとか入っていて難しそうなんですけどー
もうすぐマサキが来るので僕はこれを瞬時に覚える必要がある
本気で覚えます今から
これはやっぱり火が出ちゃうんですけども
それによる事故に対して責任を負いませんって書いてあります
これで火事になったら僕のせいです
今までありがとうございました
とりあえず開けてみよう、てか火出したいわ
中身は意外とシンプル
DVDが入ってるのと
本体ですね
うわ、これが財布です
普通にパッと見ただの、うわもう火出ないよね？
中に何かしてあるっぽいんですけども
特に何も仕掛け...はある
さー問題はこれをどうやって炎を出すかだな
どうすればいいんだろう
怖い怖い絶対これだ
絶対ここでしょ
怖いよ怖いよ
オイル？
なるほど
オイルを塗らなきゃダメなのか
普通に燃えるんじゃん
オイル買ってきます
zippo買ってきました
zippoの使い方がわからないんですよ
この部分にオイルを染み込ませるらしいですまずは。
わかんないわかんない
あ、こうか
わっわわっうーうーうーうーうー
うわ臭
いいんじゃないんですか？良い具合良い具合
オイル染み込みました
染み込ませて
DVD見てきます
なんとなくわかりました
あれ？ならなくね？
どうやってたんだろうあの人
なるほどなるほど
ありがとうYouTube
やり方がYouTubeに載ってました
これを利用してやるらしいです
これでさっきの勢いでやれば
爪がボロボロになるんだけど
これ難しいな
DVDの中の人すごい簡単にやってたんですけどこれめちゃくちゃ難しいわ
すいません
めちゃくちゃ難しいです
やっぱマジシャン系だね
多分マジック系のあれだから技術が必要なんですよ
断じて無理だよこれ
やっぱ勢いかな
あっつあっつ
あっつあっつ　ウホウホウホ
待って、できたけど衝撃的に怖かったんだけど
大事なのは勢いです
勢いがあればできます
あっあっあっあっあっあっ¡¡¡¡¡¡¡¡¡¡!!!!!!!!!
ていうのが本当はこの石をぱちっとしたらできるらしいんですけども
難しすぎます、この正規のやり方だと
とりあえず火の付く財布はあるので
マサキとうじゃうじゃなってる間にこっそりと僕はライターで火付けます
火付けて燃えるので
それでマサキが財布が勝手に燃えたと思ったらもうドッキリ成功です
ではいこう！！
はじめ：は？じゃあやってみろよ
*ターゲットと会話中*
うわ！マサキ！燃えた！
マサキ！マサキ！やばい！うわーー
・・・
(´・ω・｀)ｼｮﾎﾞｰﾝ
あっつ！
マサキ：ちょ何これ
はじめ：本当に熱いんだって